UNLV has a new head football coach today  the school introduced Barry Odom he'll  try and turn around a struggling program  Odom has over 20 years of coaching  experience most recently he served as  the defensive coordinator over at  Arkansas for the Razorbacks he also LED  Missouri's program for Four Seasons Odom  says he is ready to lead the rebels  forward  we're going to go win championships and  we're not going to back away from that  that's the goal that's a vision we want  to be the best here's the blueprint on  how we're going to go do it let's lock  arms together and let's go get it done  Rebels finished the most recent season  five and seven then UNLV fired head  coach Marcus Arroyo just last week Odom  is the 13th head coach in program  history